[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh it didn't give me any time to move
them okay for sure hey everybody what's
up how's it going happy Friday
yeah happy MORTAL KOMBAT 11 online beta
day day 4 day 4 it's a day for a stress
test day for some all things are about
to get real stressful yeah it's true and
we're about to show off here so we were
fortunate enough to get a code for this
stress test that I had to apply for
myself so unfortunately I'm on the Xbox
but it's ok I would've preferred ps4 but
I'm just happy to be playing yeah so
we've got here on the main menu some
teasers for things you could learn but
they don't want you to learn because
it's a stress test that's ok because
thanks we move lists for all the
characters so we're gonna take advantage
of that and try to try to do this the
best we can so there is you can see that
there's story mode here but it's not in
the baby so yeah yeah no no this is
obviously available this is just a
stream this is not like the beta beta
this is just a stress test just to like
test the online so this isn't even like
I think there is going to be a later
beta thing yeah like an open beta so
that everyone can get a chance to get
right out but they do have a little bit
of customization so you can get into
like see this this is the one that oh no
my stuff that I made it isn't even here
anymore I think but you can jump in and
you can do you changed these these
cosmetic parts right now you can't
actually put any augments on them so
it's just a completely cosmetic choice
but we've got some cool options here and
change your sword around I like that
they got like themes like there's this
weird cyborg theme for scorpion imma
stick with this really cool kind of
heated katana look
and you can also change around your your
little spear spear ends got a full
scorpion but I think I might go more
with this yeah and we've got some skins
here to look at as well like three
different outfits it looks like with
some different colors for each one might
go with this I kind of like this like
weird inverted kind of musics being very
extra it definitely is actually that
blues kind of good I like you know
saying that there will be a pre-order
beta but it's not an open beta very open
open so but there's a bureau of it
people are commenting on how good this
game looks yeah yeah man dude Unreal
Engine doing some work we got here I'm
gonna throw this character together
we're gonna take them into a fight here
in a second I just want to like make
sure I've got what I what I want
demon breath seems pretty cool I could I
could get down with that demon - also
looks pretty cool
why not and that's smear combo adds new
combo string to when you spear someone
in so that's why X then Y B okay yeah
I'll not do that cool someone wants to
just get right to the fight yeah we're
just checking out some of the stuff
that's available this will be really
quick so we won't even yeah we're not
gonna do anything you know the demon
slam that looks prob Jones wasa know if
there's any network problems we've had
so far I've only been stressed that lead
a few matches but everybody there will
be I mean it's it's kind of you know the
the purpose of this beta yeah yeah so
they're only two two maps three
characters
oh yeah that's second fatality for for
garrison oh you showed me that the other
day and I was like yeah dude as his
first one is literally punching someone
so hard in the back of the head I'm
probably Oh Scorpio okay
Skid Row's the Scorpion that I made
sharing scenes
I'll tell you that both of his
fatalities are mid cool cool that's good
Oh cuz a combo that just called haunted
show me some of these these combos that
he's got combo attacks okay we've got
scarlet back in this game yeah oh lordy
just going for that right off of the bag
give us we're not mortal kombat it's
been a long time since some problem with
combat but yeah that that wait scarlet
is a great box point out that's a cool
skin that's a real good skin I also like
how she has like the red bits in her
hair
how can we try the beta this is so this
is a stress past this is like she's had
to have gotten a code right like yeah
this is one of those like some more
exclusive but even even as people who
are meant to cover this game we didn't
get code sent to us like this is from my
own like I had to sign up like everyone
else yeah there wasn't a sign up you
could have done
I'll take it if you want if you want
like a normal beta test though it's
gonna be later that's just gonna be
pretty uh pre-order thing hold on since
working has the best move that I'm gonna
totally mess up yeah some say in the
game still holding out hope for striker
yeah right so the other big thing too is
the like this guest character that
everyone's kind of guessing is supposed
to be the Terminator oh man he's got to
make that movie game yeah I do that I
still want a sh kind of like as a
personal choice which would you want
like younger-looking ash lady we got
fatality one mid and then down forward
back and then - I'll do that I guess
that works
so there's gone forward back button -
and then back down down I don't know
what button one button - alright it's
probably let out first punch or second
punch first kicked second kick or
whatever it is broken down - but hey
first match we won we're gonna get a
rematch give him the run back yeah I
could try and look up some of the yeah I
just don't know that what their
specifics are but it's always mid yeah
good
how do you get the stress tested Curtis
which no you move but you'll get the
beta I'm very curious how this game will
work on switch I like this move a lot
that's really good that's one that I
actually picked him the in the menu
somebody wants to move the camera to the
corner well the court area is nice
because we keep the that's where the
like I don't know what are they call
this one you like your party leader is
left where your meters are yeah yeah so
we'd like to keep that showed so we're
not we're not really blocking anything
all we're blocking is the like I figure
out what the follow-up is for after
there you go someone somebody a dusty
here in the chat hang on Xbox one is X
button to is why is button sorry is a
and but for is B ok so it's kind of in
line with what I was thinking thank you
for that appreciate it
so if you want to do one of the
executions I would do mid down forward
back white I need figure out high enough
I'll add up to because I was washing
like the before the stream started the
hold on no trying to go for I always and
I was like I'm too long trying to like
do that stuff and
this person tapped into the matrix and
they probably believe two or three hit
me all the way that's that's a definite
combo that's there oh no it's alright
hey here's those things we got to do the
run back run back the real run back
oh no wait that's that was still there's
the second round oh [ __ ]
heck yeah this is a good fight
but I was gonna say do you want you want
like young evil bed a short you want
like ash versus the evil bed like you
want like old Bruce Campbell like like
the TV show I just want like ash from
army of Darkness you want like younger
yeah I don't know where that came from
but I like I kind of like the idea of
like a really realistic old looking
Bruce Campbell because like this game oh
you did a brutality yikes I always bet
on uppercuts cuz they'll always give you
soccer rats man did that brutality heck
yeah
the the most basic one that I think
everyone has we I'm down to go again if
they want to go again just keep keep the
keep the fights happening yeah
absolutely yeah ash with the chains but
maybe they could do like different
costumes for give us old Bruce Campbell
but also I mean you know yeah
Starla's got some really cool custom
moves and I was looking at before
oh so you can do like a hit confirm kind
of thing off at or something cuz I
definitely did a hit as I was dashing
and then they let go or maybe the grab
actually come sweet Africa I had you it
was there's no other way to do it
nice alright
oh no in my head I'm like oh you ready
yeah that was really cool I met a lot is
it does anyone know if it's still
blocked metre boom think it is and then
I think I just did it I think I'm just
not having the time
think I'm tapping in
I think I'm slowly understanding it oh
you need to not do what you're doing
right now I'm trying not to do the
uppercut because I'm like to jump in
okay mid down forward back why no its
forward back not back forward so I got
the other movie come out that's alright
though I'm gonna do it we probably find
someone else to fight yeah different
fight maybe I'll try let's get some
other characters going I was there any
interaction on the stage I know that
there's like a like whatever it's called
like a spear but not a spear you can
pick up you can jump off the walls
not as many cool interactions as the
second stage where you can literally
just like drag someone's face across a
cactus very into that move they should
implement tutorials to make players
better at combo juggling yeah I'd like
to be able to practice that's something
I've always wished fighting games are
better at was just like tutorials that
actually there's always such tutorials
that teach you like hit this button to
do this in his button I do that but
never get like really until like the
weeds of like how fighting games work
there are a couple like Skullgirls is
pretty good and then under nights in
birth IX lates has a really good
tutorial as well but the big games like
moral Kombat and especially Street
Fighter have always had
like okay thrilled the best I'd say yes
mmm dragon Baraka
some people wanted one at a Johnny Cage
and fortunately he's not the game yeah
I'd really like to see Johnny Cage he's
my boy keep some trouble loading screen
or is that just an animation I think you
just need away is a cool detail I really
like oh my god Baraka please come here
yeah I mean I think my personal favorite
has always been 9 like 909 is such a
like a love like the buzzing fanservice
to means that like I can't help but just
love that game yeah I think it's the
first Mortal Kombat that I really wanted
to weigh oh hello I didn't I'm bad at
math but I used to be I knows a lot
better when I have like I get it's I
don't play them in between releases but
when I like to get into that I may
explain how Brock is alive or nah
well uh time time time time it's all
about time travel where's the rest of
the characters ads justice trespassing
oh is it is it two buddies do I try to
figure out how to TX the mood you mean
'rebel anymore
and it's not it's not doing what I think
it should oh nice cuz like I'm either
burned a little while ago but I didn't
press right trigger at all how long yeah
stress test that goes to the 17 yeah tap
it out tap it out whole combats really
good for parties to sit back in the day
sitting around a console TV okay yeah so
when Mortal Kombat 9 came out so excited
for it my friends all the day came out
and I copy arrived I invited like seven
of my friends all day and people came
like in and out like help you really
alright I gotta leave them like you know
that I should have later like all right
let's to doing it we like just oh no
that's that's him that's him he's doing
it though he's going for it man do it
come on you got a lot of time actually
I'm like Harley hides a bomber wait it
out I'm done to rematch him didn't ever
go young souls best thing about mp9 was
Kratos I did have Kratos because I got
the X bar that ps3 version specifically
because I want to create I was cool yeah
there are there some really good like
like weird crushing moves that happen in
the first round
I saw you fight in the Coliseum dang
I was watching a pretty good way
someone's already made like compilations
videos of all the character like
interactions yeah we're all just having
things out each other and they're really
good and some of the Johnny Cage ones
the junkies they make a lot of callbacks
to like events to whatever games I like
nice background story and their intros
yes yeah so like a Cassie had an intro
for subzero or like sums you were like
Cole's I just like oh like are you here
on another training mission because
there's a whole date and then how about
10 I'm sorry X where she like shows up
at each other turns out to be like a
training exercise so yeah like the all
the intros are like referencing events
from the previous games which is like
nice damn service yes that goes full
screen I love it
oh yeah for the crime we just redid
James gun oh shoot
that's that's a thing I was really not
expecting that yeah at this point it
seemed they were very done with that Oh
youngsil says yeah I didn't like it at
first but it does a good job of kind of
like not being too loud so it kind of
fades out when you're playing someone I
found Twitter oh they loved Erika was oh
man Erika Joon she was saying how she
feels like Mortal Kombat is one of the
few fighting games that actually like
really cares about like the design of
their UI like both aesthetically and
functionality and and I would kind of
agree yeah that like some some UI
especially anime fighting games can get
real messy it's it's really loud there's
a lot of colors and everything it it's
good that it stands out but I also like
when like it's noticeable but you don't
yeah I think Mortal Kombat like they
stick a really nice clean balance with
their UI that I really really like I'm a
fan yeah also I prefer fighting games
that use that kind of like I don't know
what you'd call it like that
I get it's a throwback like the way they
designed the grid it makes it easier for
them to add DLC characters and make it
unpredictable well like other ones it's
in a grid in a way where like very much
you only have room for this many
characters I also just realized I think
whenever we go with your touch screen
our
camera might be over the only characters
that are selectable oh are they
so it's scarlet Baraka I'll check on
that and scorpion
alright so I'm gonna give scarlet go
it's okay ray 2k6 is reptile or bust
[Applause]
I don't remember at all I think you guys
okay I'm just gonna there's a while
where I was trying to main him this is
open he's not bad to I signed up for the
website and gotten he didn't then you're
out of luck but don't worry there is
going to be a data flows pre-ordered
never said lamb but probably within its
route because I barely all the other one
an open beta which if you have to excuse
me scorpion please no so this is a flat
reptile was announced maybe not I
haven't seen rough you might have been
like in some of the like side screen
stuff but okay he's been efficient okay
people are saying reptile wasn't fat I
just don't that's weird for some reason
I don't remember him in 10 bring back
Newton Sybok oh yeah hell yeah box great
Johnny Cage Johnny Cage for sure I love
him so much I love Cassie because she's
basically just Johnny but maybe more
read like I feel like I could hang out
with Johnny you know yeah I'm really
excited for the like this stuff they're
setting up in the story where it's like
older like slightly more mature Johnny
Cage
Oh Johnny cake yeah yeah like oh my god
what was wrong with me such a loser I I
really liked the ninja stuff and I
really like smoke yeah like playing wise
maybe not my favorite character visually
but I loved playing smoke and I really
wanted smoke to be back I know he kind
of showed up it's like any part of the
Tri board thing it's not the same it's
not the same I prefer to like a separate
character like I also like like sect or
on fire and all those guys so I feel
like Scarlett is actually more of like a
realized character in this game a lot of
her moves are actually like I don't know
cuz she's got a lot of different like
Mortal Kombat's always had a history of
like hidden DLC characters or characters
and Scarlett was one of those secret
characters for a long time where
everyone's like oh there's like a red
version of katana and Jade and Molina
hidden characters but she never actually
existed and then the added her innate
reveal as DLC
which is really cool but I always felt
like you can do it oh no it's him
scorpion it's all good
scorpion doesn't yell get overkill and
he does his thing that time but yeah I
really like that they brought her back
and that she feels more like fully
realized as a character why would you do
that do you believe this some people are
saying we don't got Kenzi anymore yeah
no can she
I wanna Becca gonna make up I hope so
I like a lot of the combat kids contrary
yeah the kind of other people think do
people not like the combat no people
don't like them for some reason whoa why
not I mean I couldn't tell you is it a
like aesthetic thing or more of a
playing thing because I know a lot of
people really love like Kong Jin and and
I like Cassie yeah yeah I can't not pick
that mask that's a good mask
surberg says he won't miss Takeda Aaron
Black is coming back you're a black
school I do like that a lot of these
choices are aesthetic now so you just
like oh yeah I definitely prefer that
pick whatever whatever you like that's
got to be really tough to balance it
like to to make these characters stand
out and still be identifiably that
character while also allowing you to
like change like everything about them
like visually you know yeah yeah cuz you
can make her like blue right what isn't
blue like Tom is blue that's not how
that works so I wanted to use I want use
this move because it makes people throw
up it's his live this is live this is
totally live we're live right live as
hell they want Quan Chi Quan Chi was
pretty cool I like him
blood flow Bob Jones wants to know has
there ever been a fighter in only one
game ooh that's a good question
I'm sure there's there's probably
someone like like a main one not like a
guest character to Perry Tania was only
an X oh yeah that's right yeah hot
places we're not getting smoked yeah it
seems like we're probably not getting
smoked assuming all those things were
true which that sounds like it's fun all
right cool
I got I got a scarlet set up now so we
go back in company were saying chameleon
yeah only in one game I reckon Molina in
this one I feel like we'd have to I
don't know
I mean she's hella dead but mr. Mortal
Kombat acts but also it doesn't matter
cuz time travel yeah I mean Luke hangs
showing up in a lot of those stuff and
he's supposed to be dead at certain
points to Jade's back meet drama and
mocap were all only in one game all
mocap ever mocap oh yeah I want I want
more silly stuff in mortal combat like I
like a lot of this but I kind of Miss
the the silly nonsense my skull daggers
pretty cool
this guy's got a cool custom outfit - I
think his is set up the same way -
please do a fatality this time all right
man you try new try you got you got
scarlet stuff pulled up over there a
taller what
Scarlet's oh yes absolutely some scarlet
moves oh I'll see you here fatalities
yeah oh there there yeah bloody mess and
they're both mids cool cool ones three
and ones for so downtown for would be
from mid-range got it downtown Ford be
fire looks good like them making 40 more
of like a sympathetic character
gentlemen is Sam probably not gonna win
this I'll try my best you just want to
put my face on that cactus I'm not here
for a scorpion
he wants to move the cam to the side is
enough Center I swear we have it
centered for you because you asked see
this is what happens just wants to hit
me on the side of the things I'm not
going for it do this though back it's on
the side now we've been asking for it
scorpion please don't do this to me it's
gonna look like I'm trying to timer scam
you but I just don't want to get thrown
against the the cactus oh there's my
parry then I timed completely the center
was kind of lame I mean so the reason we
picked Center is because if you put it
the center is the only thing that isn't
blocking and visual information like now
that we have it on the side we're
blocking it's always a game of like
trying to not cover up a lot of
important when I just stopped it so it's
a low
yikes
there it is he is what he wanted he got
it he's gotta know a fatality if he
doesn't who are you what are you doing
here
I'm not gonna rematch him cuz I know
that the rematch is gonna come out the
same
well cyber growls to know if the costume
changing is like injustice too so it's
all these usual this there's no like so
it's visual and then you get to pick
your own abilities that you put on it
yeah it's not like we're like the
abilities we're specifically tied to the
gear stick go back
use your projectiles and defense moves
terrible I'm gonna let you know a thing
I've played this character a grand total
of maybe like three times
I think her main projectile is like a
quarter circle backward in wise but I'm
not even sure about that if you do have
any tips on how to how to like do this
stuff cuz I can only learn by playing
people yeah I'm totally into here I'm
out I'm keepin it real with you chief
I'm trying I'm stepping outside of my
comfort zone I do like this purple theme
this guy's guy
all right there we go there's that right
the purple lights Gary it's got some
Kneedler stuff going going on
heck yeah yeah the move isn't as intense
as I thought it would be I jump right
into it well that's the other thing I'm
mortal combat that I don't think it's
projectiles just go through each other
you know you don't actually like collide
oh this is fine
ooh maybe I'll step off a scarlet for a
bit so I was asking when we think we'll
see some switch gateway yeah that's a
good question like to see how it looks
on the switch I feel like a lot of
people are just curious yeah here I'm
gonna let me go to the next person it's
got here what did I miss you missed some
very good people
oh yeah down there's a play as slow as
people are saying it feels a lot more
like like 9 which makes me happy I
prefer that honestly and I think it's
because from what I hear they took away
the run I haven't been able to
accidentally run like I do sometimes so
I think that might actually be the case
oh we declined maybe you're saying
something's wrong with the sound
it doesn't sound off to you oh yeah let
us know yeah let us know it's the same
guy again adjustments oh I'm up to two
nice hello hello yeah yeah there we go
it's a very close win odds too so
took run away doesn't cabal use run
during one of his duties he still has
that from what I'm being told from what
I've seen how do you have this game art
it's it's just the network tests sign up
for for code on the site as soon as they
they announced it and was fortunate
enough to get a code so he could jump in
and play I'm sure you can change up for
place on if you know like how she plays
I feel like I could just take a lot more
like getting in and just finding out
what her cuz I don't even know what her
base attacks are at this point so I know
like what I could do to complement what
she has at least kind of like have an
understanding of what scorpion to do
yeah so I can kind of build off of the
basic understanding groundwork no J of
the pre-order data shouldn't be trying
to hit this guy's head against a card I
should probably try to fight this man
was a single dad and doesn't feature
Scorpio I'm in sign me up alright that
sounds like a thing
Oh sipping something music the sound
back oh no that's what happens can't
blow the vid on PC right uh I don't
think so it's only ps4 and Xbox ok pcs
always get left behind on weird to me
when it comes to like yeah let's just do
one of these get some more violence it
is kind of weird though that a lot of
people just don't want to test things on
PC maybe they're just that confident in
them so one says you squirt being a next
match please don't worry you were
already born doing it yeah we're already
on that sperm you train there we go so
I'm able to kind of like try some things
so that's exciting
I kind of I kind of recall the bit of a
rocket too which was fun
this is a good time
there we go oh you can straight up just
grab people by okay sounds nice we're
learning dusty saying recruiter beta is
in two weeks
well there you go game cross-platform oh
yeah crime says March 2017 Savannah will
you go oh I bet on it I bet wrong come
on do it do it do it I believe in my
maracas the back in alright I'm done -
Ziggy tried they try to do it and I
think they were like nope I don't have
it that looks painful that was kind of
like a fatality but like in Reverse do a
friendship our friendships on this one I
hope so
babe a ladies I'm really surprised that
a garis because he controls time doesn't
have like a reverse causality oh I
skipped my wine
yeah he should have bought like a
fatality where he like like reading
thermal off our shoes yeah just like
turn to dust
oh sorry not ribs lost our graves lost
our kids I mean they also turn the
skeletons that one specific I'm thinking
all right I'm gonna get my stuff sorted
out here I'm not gonna get my stuff
sorted out here
there we go
Travis is I think cross-platform between
different systems should work perfect
for fighting games I don't think you
have an advantage on PC or console I'd
agree
sure I think yeah like non-accounting
free be like people on PC anything weird
like that but usually like there's place
on those themes for that anyway but yeah
I think fighting games makes the most
sense as far as cross play go yeah which
is always a good thing especially in
fighting resources mr. he says we get a
fatality I will legit donate $30 to the
stream we have a like a doughnut I don't
think we have a donation thing but I bet
you're that in just getting the fatality
yeah I really appreciate that these the
sweet jumps
oh man it just charged across it's a
cool helmet for coming on it's still not
comfortable you know what I'll do it one
more time I feel like I feel like I can
feel it I feel like I can do it you
think you can do it I think I can buy
that I believe we try to memorize
scorpions fatality
you gotta internalize your thing Johnny
Cage he's the most on brand for me
churches you wanted this game striker
strengthened looking pretty cool so da
Milo and firm like Jax I'm senior and
it's Jackie Jackie that animation is so
slick every time
there he goes
Peter / next I want to do it sausage
axes enter from the lease does this say
you're gonna do that right away
oh great flex was the wishes the MK
cutscene for the live action like okay
time to study this back down down X
mid-range got it
you gotta be a little closer probably
Tammy plays out to AH they left I won
one game a 1-1 game I could have
probably just done the uppercut
brutality if I really wanted to but I'm
trying to figure out these fatalities
I'll roast chickens back yeah we're
trying to get that fatalities going no
luck though we haven't seen no one's
done one on us we haven't I saw someone
who had him like unlock before though
you know what I'm gonna mix it up do a
fatality yes you definitely can yeah
it's cool this the stage is a throwback
to like one of the original stages it's
just tilted like turn to the side a bit
[Music]
Dooley shows and doing himself in mortal
combat that'd be pretty cool yeah your
dreams list just consistent it have to
be real good
I miss okay so that's a good overhead
that goes from like half the screen I'd
like to block please like it's it's not
like a thing that's been his army ball
daddy weird so very cool
I think there was like the one thing
where it was inside of his arm like shot
it out it like a spider-man thing the
movie the movies
there's so that would make a lot of
sense there we go there's your brutality
all right this is easy go to that oh and
she's actually just taking in all the
blood yeah it's a it's a special ones
there's a whatever fatalities a nine
yeah I like how there is a like an easy
go to blood you tality for anyone who
wants to do it it's it's just there you
end up doing it by accident the first
time and then you're like ah I know the
cool things now
[Music]
I wish I knew literally any combo string
for her cuz it's just been like one
singular attack after the other all
right it's totally a waste because it's
not gonna get me the next round but I'm
here for the spectacle you know okay so
that doesn't deflect things that's good
to know to the test that more characters
does it continue don't think so
you really cool if it did though I
haven't said though
yikes
let me just not do anything jtrail says
try one one for that seller to combo
alright don't even have a second hit on
the on the one come on do that do it
you've got to do it and believe in you
now we've got to go for a third round
though cuz I won the first one I don't
know why that of all things makes me
uncomfortable yeah like there's a lot of
a lot of really gross violent things in
this game but it's the one where he
picks his teeth that gets it yeah we're
playing on xbox right now no which do we
enjoy more this is skull rolls one to
four I think I want to play more of this
just to like see what it does that's
good that's a good call up let's need to
find a better way to implement it now
and not yet cut apart
for hikes I got it to land once I know
it's I know it's thing no it's real all
right cool how many characters can you
pick in the bag just three swords say as
far as like like an omni online like
Tesco's this like I feel like I'm not
like got me on the backswing yeah I get
the grab
please out a new character named
chiropractor oh definitely
I'll take it it was a bit overkill but
I'll take it
oh heck yeah I know exactly when do to
start off the next round - totally
botched it nevermind
okay I'm into that the banners got some
real good range oh that's fine oh there
we go
yay finally that's his second one - oh
nice it's not the one where he rips off
their face
excellent so that's that's that's fresh
content I'm into it no don't don't
rematch actually I'm gonna try to find
someone else it was a very good way to
round that out though
mr. Pokemon lover I'd love to have a
fight with you
heck yeah well go I'll give Baraka to go
now because I feel like we've been
bouncing between Scorpion and Scarlett
for a bit trying to find I think it's
this one Special Forces Special Forces
desert command I really like the best
interactable so far in this dress test
is definitely the cactus it just do you
think they're just gonna throw him into
it but they just dragging them on it too
it's very good
I saw you fight in the Coliseum
sub-zero that's real cool like that move
it's kind of come here come here
I can do that pretty reliably now how do
you lack it feels really good like for a
network test signals pretty good for a
network test it feels granted we're also
playing roaming in the car again
yeah okay
hey yeah so once as long as pops master
or black well we'll see when the full
game comes out yeah at least so far
based on this test it
I sang I liked I move a lot and it's
done a lot for him oh I completely
missed my fatal blow in he gotta fight
him again though oh it's just a little
bit of teabag and I guess guess giving
codes oh wait man if we had Jose to give
away I'd love to but we we didn't even
get given codes for this yeah
like I this is from my own like I had to
sign up on the website myself also crime
pointed out that apparently they said
they will start sending more invites
starting today till the end of the day
oh there yeah maybe hour until the end
of the beta so they might get mine on
the weekend so yeah so if you signed up
for it and you didn't get a code right
now it's keep an eye out because you
might get a code like later tonight
actually makes a lot of sense for a
stress test - to start off with like we
know we can handle this slowly add more
more people in waves you can kind of
measure it out I'm just gonna stick with
Morocco because I need to I need get his
business going
holding out on those codes gotta bring
back the extra brutality so you've got
like x-ray moves built into like combo
Enders now instead of extra instead of
the the the special moves which is an
interesting choice but kind so wants us
to go back to scarlet I can get some
more Scarlett's up there I'm just trying
to mix it up a bit like with all all
three of the characters it's kinda nice
if we're only three I'm just gonna get
taken out here oh it's okay I'll do this
though oh that's no good
I don't remember the MK chest minigame
and had a big deception ago that sounds
amazing though do I want on combat
carpets come back on
on all that dumb stuff I think that guy
just gave that to me because he like put
his controller down see definitely he's
got my number and he knows it well any
plans streaming today probably for
another I'm time to keep shooting
embarrassed online for another cop yeah
oh okay
this dress oh I miss know what so I feel
like let me have the last one I would
say uh this is definitely a little bit
slower more like what will come at 9:00
yeah which I'm varying so yeah it's a
light gray yeah X is a very dark color
palette that I vastly prefer this color
throw this dimension twelve nine nine
how to call
yes good way again if you put a lot of
like nine it feels more like back they
prefer that obviously personal he likes
only got in if you like the way nine
played at all you sure and jumping isn't
as good which is a very hard thing for
me to adjust to I'm sure you can tell
because I still love jumping have you
tried the customization yeah a little
Bowl yes there is a little bit of
customization not full customization
they like you can't choose the abilities
that are on armor pieces can't you can't
really mess with everything yeah but
there's a little bit so you can change
like the cops or cosmetic items and you
can change some of your attacks
so I think this guy has that one combo
down it's very flashy but I think it
might be one of the only things maybe I
can kind of maybe no never like he's got
he's got a lot of stuff
so I'm saying after how you got your
head punished off you turn your system
off just be like nah that's fine
yep anything new reveals in the beta I
think it might be like a similar build
to one in the first like combat I should
put down my banner more I think that's
like down down one of the kicks
like the music's going on the background
to
yeah that's fine
I can't wait to actually like practice
this is it like what I do manage to pull
off things that I'm there are there like
parts that you can change that change
different attributes for your care but
but they're separate from the cosmetic
so yeah have you kept the cosmetic look
you want and then separate and then set
that stuff inside of those cosmetic yes
so like no longer you don't have to be
like oh I don't like the way this looks
but I want it for this
ah I love that cactus a lot oh no we
don't have maraca stuff pulled up at all
nope we're just gonna do one of those
that's fine cutting loose oh he went
right for the rematch this is this is
good I don't know I haven't seen
anything but that was kind of a funny
thing I'd be down for it to be here
again
when he's actually he's actually pulling
back and forth this is trying to got me
it's got my number
who is who on screen Baraka right now
the one who's getting them kind of
worked over so not that you can't like
if you spam trying to do in like an
interactive or things too much you just
can't do it but you always come back let
me just whip everything yeah that's fair
and the fatality yeah so maybe mids
further back he is very far back that
looks really good it's like a real like
a metal gear rising yeah I'm down to I'm
down to move on now yeah actually you
know what yeah if he wants to switch up
characters I'm down to switch up
character so I'll keep fighting with
this guy he's he's very good he knows
how to do the fatalities the solar can
ask for you know
[Music]
Rena contestant
so I think he was able to combo because
he started the combo before the match
was over box night I don't think like he
was doing it yeah this guy's good
content you know what I'm talking about
he knows what's up I know I gotta run my
like my cool combo I learned
do it I can I can see that I guess I
want the silly stuff to come back in
Mortal Kombat yeah and you're like the
Crypt stuff yeah I feel like if the
scheme doesn't have a crypt for Miss
nomer it's like almost everyone has
yeah yeah Jake signal from the venue is
good point oh man that move is so cool
just waiting for you to jump oh it's all
move triple oof
yikes uh Scarlett's not not doing it for
me points out dang this guy is good
yeah right you got your fiddle blow I do
it's not gonna do much though there we
go we got a brutality that's exactly
what people were asking him asking for
we got we got people's heads getting
punched off a nun to run it back though
get back in the in the flow of scarlet
cuz it's I feel I feel so lost without
having the ability actually does stuff
like uh training room
it's not the point of the stress test
but man don't lose your head
these are the jokes yikes
oh I didn't realize that's pickets on on
B to plop that and we're done there we
go that's what I want every time
oh I shouldn't wait it too
the framerate been very smooth
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's that's fine maybe yeah maybe
this time we move on to a little person
is the stress test on PC no it's not I
wish it were how's it going guys it's
going pretty good
yeah the game feels really good I'm very
impressed with the the online connection
stuff but is there an option change your
style I can MKX replaced by
customization both like you can change
your style but you can also customize
that individual style yeah
I'm kind of sad the Goku declined to
fight FTC Clinic says they're building a
fight stick in celebration for this game
thank you I love fightsticks my building
custom fight sticks - scorpion mirror
match thing take it to the similar zone
though yes it's not abated as much as it
is a stress test so they're just trying
to get people online and playing yeah
probably some other division maybe some
of this every now and then because I
want to practice on time doing the dark
zone yeah I was a good time we were
doing the dark zone like pre but no one
else was there because it's still like
that early access period I mean I think
it took a lot of good stuff that they
learned from injustice but it still
feels very distinct in combat sky got
one of those too
there we go my favorite I can see them
on the screen
I don't think you can in the stress test
but that is a good feature that hope
still makes a return does the game feel
too slow you're saying it feels like 9
so if you're in a 9 it's it's pretty on
par with that but yeah it's it's getting
used to not playing things like 10 like
people are mentioning that jumps aren't
the thing anymore and your boy loves
jumping because of course you hear what
happened a judgement yes yeah
unfortunately I still up in the air
right now as far as the final what
happened to the American relief
I hope that there's a lot of stuff that
might change I like that move a lot
that's probably gonna be something that
I keep with scorpion like when I
actually play there not a fatality not
an exciting brutality but a brutality
nonetheless cool so you never realize
where we were secure Oh Dave's gone if
you had to pick one secure oh absolutely
no question I'd like to play days gone
but I'm definitely more interested in
secure Oh
oh well you guys stream sector oh I mean
yeah when uh whatever word you have that
game and we're allowed to stream at work
that play three minutes
I'm sure table oh yeah that boy Tay
you're probably it'll probably mean say
if I have this where's the jumping like
half slow motion yeah it's very very
slow yeah
I can I prefer that it's very Mortal
Kombat 9 I think a lot of people just
got into mortal combat with X Y and are
not used to nine I'm kind of shocked how
many people were like oh it looks so
slow and I'm like no this is kind of how
more combats always been I think it's
just this X was faster I like that move
a lot
it's cuz very defensive apparently this
is not as slow as there was not it was
not as slow as this and we need to get
our facts I mean I'm just saying that it
placed similarly to how I feel I
remember Mortal Kombat Appling I think I
can't I can't actually say that it's
like yeah 30% faster cuz I was bad at
math but he also doesn't have those
numbers to say that if you were to
compare it to age of previous Mortal
Kombat game time visit that in a second
that's fine
oh no I went for the teleport I was
gonna teleport I wish I could figure out
how to do any other move after I pull
someone over because that's not that's
not the way I want to do it if I knew
what my texts were it'd probably be a
lot higher but if I just set here in
played scope you know a whole bunch I'll
probably be able to figure out like ah I
can do like this and this and this
pull them over do one of those like it's
it's there I just don't have the the
knowledge for what they've changed or
what he has or what the property is for
them all are let's just do it again go
back here there we go
so mate is just all the way downtown
that's not and that's just the reveal
trailer fatality and I think it's also
the first time we've seen this one on
the streams so that's good we did it I
came in I did a fatality I'm feeling
pretty good about it
job time to rematch go again
oh the min is just the placeholder okay
probably should done a little more
research on wait just a placeholder for
it which is why on the page is it only
scorpion today no no other characters
but there's only scorpion Baraka and you
know they only have three in the stress
test and how much time you have left I
might switch to another one but scorpion
is the one that I at least know some of
us a force still and it holds over so
that's what I've been trying to figure
out cuz I've been pressing right trigger
net hasn't been doing it some even just
getting the timing wrong or like yeah
cuz like as pushing it all through that
and I didn't change you up but I've
enhanced stuff by pressing is like two
buttons some wondering if it's got to be
like oh so it's just another attack but
it's not right trigger oh it's from what
I just did seems weird because why would
you change that
we can do short hops okay so that's
that's good to know
cuz you have a so that means if I like
yes that that enhanced that and I didn't
press right trigger at all
Dania you've done human smoker to be
candid I still want to mince no I mean
time travel man yeah anything's possible
when time travels involved just are
watching what characters available only
scorpion
[Music]
this guy's being very careful anytime I
decided I should try to grab he he's
smart enough to not let me do it do it I
believe in you he's trying I think that
puts him at one so we better get the run
back
well they had more character stress test
no don't abandon me not that I'm aware
of
yeah they haven't made any announcement
to do it but I hope they do I think this
might be just like a like an older bill
because if if the button for enhancing
moves is different that's that's a big
different thing yeah
when's the next combat cast I think next
week say announced that they weren't
doing one this week and they said that
they might be coming I think they're
coming back
hungry yeah I'm feeling it
see I'm gonna do school raka again I
think I want I want to be good with
Baraka and want to understand Baraka cuz
I kind of missed him and I'm glad that
he's back Boone has a surprise for us
next week oh I don't know what it is
yeah that's her I was gonna say I might
skipper because I think we've seen all
the dialogue things so far
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
that I wish I kind of understood what
their input method well sport because
sometimes it seems to work more like
mine
yeah yeah yeah nice okay I'll take it
it's not taste the blades are dirt uh I
think my issue might be more that I
don't know any of the combos off my hand
top of my head for this and it seemed
like the ones that I tried to remember
for sparkling didn't really carry over
but there were some that ended up
popping out anyway so I mean the timing
doesn't seem too bad on the ones that
I've sort of figured out it's just more
of a lack of knowledge at this point
yeah
do some don't fatality guys oh you
missed my fatality I did earlier look
cool that looked like I knew what I was
doing
do it again do it again
I don't know if this does anything
different but we didn't have the list
pulled up so I'm just gonna so good I
should I should have told you like oh
man
Baraka let's do it it is uh back down
back to and that's close okay close with
a K because of course
sure
no no I'll just want to figure out this
guy was just messing with me
I'm wondering if is a more efficient way
to - - yeah yeah I don't know if I'd
waste it because it probably wouldn't
kill him and then I wouldn't be able to
do it the next round yeah you only get
one per fight two sorts so it's kind of
like if you use it it's it's a it's a
weird thing to kind of wrap your head
around you're like oh yeah I got my
revenge mechanic I better use it back in
that corner next to that truck is the
opposite of is the way you're supposed
to go do another one I was like oh maybe
I can catch him on the sky wants to do a
rematch okay I'll do this rematch and
then we'll call it that
okay I want at least give him that yeah
I don't remember if we're even or not
but I'm definitely down to fight him
again if he wanted to
this is the last one I've got a like
I've got to make you gotta make this
work come on
okay that's good that's cool so let's
ship damage going on with that so if I
do
so I think I think it's just both both
hunches if you a bunch of tax to burn it
or both both kicks nope that's not
I'll grab and slam him in the car yeah
yeah can't I can't figure out how to do
this meter burn and this thing okay what
it's well it's gotta close though no we
got we got one fatality ourselves we got
a couple of brutalities we played all
the characters we want some we lost some
was a pretty pretty good time I won't
play more Mortal Kombat yeah yeah
joining us guys yeah thanks for hanging
out I'm excited too I'm gonna feel like
the pre-order beta it's hopefully a lot
more characters we can mess with yeah
well thanks guys yeah oh man you know
we're doing next week GTCC happening is
happening next week so you've got a cool
cool stream that you're doing yep we're
doing the indie mix yeah yeah we do
every year where we have a bunch of
indie developers on to show off their
cool games I look for that you born
Michaels gonna be hosting that yeah
exciting and then yeah I think we have
like a lot of announcements and needs
going out throughout that week and I'm
sure we'll probably play SEC hero next
week because it comes out next week yes
at some point we'll definitely play that
game look for that and see you guys next
time
goodbye everybody have a good day
[Music]
[Music]